c'était en 2004 une époque glorieuse
pour le bloc québécois dans les sondages
et externe dans sa circonscription de
lac saint jean saguenay sébastien gagnon
marchait fièrement dans les pas d'un des
fondateurs du bloc québécois lucien
bouchard il était l'un des cinquante
quatre députés bloquistes le deuxième
meilleur cru depuis 1993
comme bien d'autres il a eu le souffle
coupé par la descente aux enfers de 2011
je me suis questionnée sur ce que le
bloc devrait rester à ottawa
est ce que le loup devrait tout
simplement quitter puis on investisse
nos énergies à québec au parti québécois
aujourd'hui il appuie sans réserve le
candidat bloquiste de son ancien comté
mais aux côtés de sam un gode ro vous ne
verrez pas les anciens chef bloquiste
seul le chef du parti québécois venus
l'appuyer semble soulever les passions
merci de leur présence dans la salle
l'ex-député péquiste denis trottier
il a été approché par le bloc pour être
candidat mais il a refusé et on me
demanderait pour être candidat
pourquoi il n'avait pas accepté les
stations parce qu'un trop qu'il faut
sentir du dos d'un accès sûr qu'il faut
faire et personnellement je le sentais
pas et il n'est pas le seul
son ex collègue yves françois blanchet
ministre sous le gouvernement marois a
lui aussi été courtisé par le bloc
lui aussi a dit non est-ce que ça se
peut que le bloc soit 10 peigne à la fin
du mois d'octobre 2015 clairement son
analyse
il le sait et durs envers les troupes
souverainistes mais on peut pas
prétendre qu'il y en a présentement un
nouvel élan au renouveau du québec mon
jeu ces plâtres mais je 100 % à leurs 11
pas sans cet élan à l'os et 2 pour le
bloc de faire le tri mais pourquoi n'y
at il pas des landes au coeur même dans
le berceau du seul parti souverainiste
sur la scène fédérale
il faut qu'une fois un accord fouet la
raviver cette fois là où il a ravivé
pour que les rares reprennent cette
ferveur qui peut-être été un peu mis de
côté merci de nous emmener la vague
orange jusqu'au lac saint jean à alma
bastion souverainiste
il faut regarder dans la cour du npd
pour retrouver ceux qui ont longtemps
milité pour le bloc québécois
je t'aime je te demande sportsquébec
quoi je demande même du bloc québécois
mais ça je m'arrête un fonds national
istres c'est bien certain mais leur son
élection fédérale
moi je pense à bloc a fait son temps
j'étais très militaire d'un militant
j'avais quand même décidé de voter pour
le npd et j'ai même oublié de porter mon
chandail comme celui de gerald qui est
stop harper il y avait même des
personnes qui m'ont dit monsieur duceppe
c'est mon ami mais je voterai pas pour
eux je vois très provoc et bloc
maintenant je vais arrêter un [ __ ] que
le bloc québécois avait fait son temps
la chroniqueuse mais rien n'égale parle
de politique et on entend souvent parler
sur les ondes de la radio locale son
verdict est sans appel il n'y a pas ce
sentiment de c'est un des nôtres il faut
l'encourager qui est assortiment
fréquents dans les régions et
particulièrement celle du lac-saint-jean
cartes et bleu un tie break de plus que
les autres souvent mais tapas avec
gilles duceppe est un même puce avec le
bloc québécois le bloc québécois ne nous
a pas manqué au cours des dernières
années ce qui se passe au lac saint jean
est surtout le signe d'une crise plus
profonde croit ces politologues
c'est très certainement révélateur des
difficultés qu'ils éprouvent le parti au
delà du parti
je dirais surtout de l'idée de ce qu'on
se fait d'un vote utile
quoi qu'il en soit pour sébastien gagnon
le bloc c'est une histoire d'amour qui
doit aller jusqu'au bout et il le dit
avec un évident pincement au coeur de
rester fidèles lorsqu'il me concerne
c'est ce
c'est la voit prendre comme bien
d'autres il n'ose pas prédire si dans sa
région
la récolte du bloc québécois sera bonne
en 2015
mais il compte cultiver l'espoir jusqu'à
la fin de la campagne ici julie dufresne
radio canada alma